oh oh oh
i'm way too pregnant for a scent like
this that is awful
that brings me back
hey everybody conan o'brien here and i'm
joined by
sonia reed and aaron blair or as i call
him blay the host of team coco's podcast
good game
nice try they talk to their favorite
comedians actors
and gamers about the video games they
love and the games they hate
that's the part i'd be more interested
in if you haven't subscribed
go subscribe right now it's a terrific
show anyway
this package showed up at my door from
these two they just sent it to me
i don't know what it is should i be
scared is this okay here's why we sent
you this package
everyone back in the day would bring
their computers to
somebody's basement and then they'd play
games and it's called
a lan party which is a local area
network party but wait a minute if
you're the whole idea of being on a
computer is that you don't have to be
together
back before the internet there were you
could oh that far ago
okay did you ever get together with your
friends in kind of a lan party
friends that's the first step here we go
tell me more of this friends concept
jesus christ he just learned what llan
was i grew up and this will uh date me
and it's about time someone dated me
he's out of control not even funny it's
not even funny
exhausting i remember they taught a
computer class
at my high school brookline high
and they gave us those cards you see in
old movies
where you had to like punch out your
code and then feed it into a giant thing
that was like going bleep blur
lower and basically what it would do is
four plus four equals eight if you spent
like an hour
on it that's the kind of computer that i
was familiar with i decided this is
never going anywhere
so i was not doing that i was up in my
room
i had a shawl pulled up around my neck
because it was boston and it was cold
and i was writing poetry
and looking out the window occasionally
and having a little cough
that was my childhood so i don't know
what you're talking about
sonia we have been to lan parties and
it's like it's a happy
memory we don't lug our computers over
to each other's houses but it is such a
special
moment in time and i really wish that we
could go back to it yeah
i wish that we could have that
experience all over again
well if if only there was some way we
could if only there was
yeah we came up with a lan party candle
to try to you know recapture the magic
of what it was like to be at a lan party
look at that this is a scent that you
guys think is going to recreate
the emotions the sensory
feelings and inputs of a lan party
yeah so let's just crack crack it open
okay it's got a
it's a nice and do i smell it yeah
oh oh oh
god oh
that is awful that is that brings me
back
i think we nailed it that it because i
didn't go to one but this is i think we
nailed it this is
if uh if uh if they evacuated
uh high school and told everyone leave
right now
and all everyone left the gym including
all their gym clothes
because it was like a chernobyl type
incident and they had just played a
basketball game and everyone just
dropped all their sweaty gym clothes
threw on their regular clothes and ran
without showering and left the clothes
there
and then people came back in i'm gonna
say six years later
this is the scent this is awful what it
just
lingers in the air after you oh i was
gonna say sona are you okay
no you know what i'm i'm way too
pregnant for a scent like this
it's like i i survived the first
trimester without any nausea and this
is legitimately making me want to vomit
into
like a trash can now this is going to
affect your unborn children when they're
born they're going to come out
and they're going to look like uh you
know sort of like steve
jobs you know what i mean they're going
to look like someone who was working on
a computer in 1977. they're going to
come out with
turtlenecks and turtlenecks and glasses
and they're going to be very
they're going to be very argumentative
with you right away
why do i keep smelling it i know i'm
doing it too it's like picking at a scab
i will tell you the color is exactly i'm
not even doing a joke
that's earwax mine is a greenish earwax
if i had a lot of earwax already and
then i had been swimming for several
days
in a bog in northern england
i went to a doctor and he extracted all
of the wax
and then put it into this little tin
that's what it would look like
that's what it smells like too
it looks like it smells it does look
like a smell it's got
there's a very strong body odor is that
right sona there's a very strong body
odor the top of the sticker says body
odor and a hint of
ramen are you getting the ramen are you
pulling the ramen through
i couldn't smell it enough to actually
analyze the smell
no i'm getting a little bit of that
salty ramen it's aerated a little
i'm also getting the strong
strong odor of male virginity
would you say you officially endorse the
the land candle conan let me see do i
have a saw left no i don't
yes i officially endorse the land candle
the human soul weighs seven pounds it's
the easiest way to lose weight
after my third reading of a podcast ad
it was gone
i don't think there's any better use of
your money out there than to
get this land candle uh you should get
one you should get two
if at all possible you gotta get this
candle you gotta get it
it's podswag potswag.com slash
teamcoco podslash.com
wait a minute small stroke brought about
by the candle and that is a side effect
i'm telling you up front you will have a
stroke
but guess what strokes actually can be a
little beneficial
they can they can they make you
appreciate life
more and then you get all this physical
therapy and then you're like yeah
podswag.com slash
team coco pot slash
pod i'm blacking out
i'm blacking out but i'm very uh i've
never felt
more strongly about a product somebody
somebody please get the candle away from
him
no no i put it on the floor is that far
enough oh look
it's already repelling mice
how do you keep smelling it i don't even
understand your nose is in it
you know what it's like a wine that has
to open up
and i'm starting to come around on it